Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys. This is.
Rob and we are back again with another installment of our beyond Omega level
series, where we discuss the most powerful characters in comics.
And today we're doing one of the most mysterious and powerful characters of the
DC universe and the character that several of you guys have been requesting in
the comments for awhile, the Phantom stranger.
So the Phantom stranger was created by John broom and Carmen in Pitino,
and first appeared and Phantom stranger. Number one in 1952.
And when I say that the Phantom stranger is a mysterious character.
I mean that for many years we knew absolutely nothing about his origin or his
true identity. It was not until 1987 when DC published secret origins,
number 10,
that we got any insight whatsoever to who the Phantom stranger really was.
And even then we didn't exactly get a great deal of clarity as the issue
presented us with four conflicting yet equally possible versions of his origin
story.
And so the first of these possible origins was adapted from a legend that dates
back to the 13th century in Europe,
and is commonly referred to as the wondering Jew. Now, as the legend goes,
this was a man of Jewish heritage,
the Tawny Christ on his way to his crucifixion and as punishment was cursed to
walk the earth until price return. Now in the version told in secret origin,
number 10,
the Phantom stranger confesses to a priest that he was once a man named Isaac
who lived in Bethlehem during the time of Christ's birth.
Now Herod the King of Judea gives an order to kill every male child in the
region in an effort to kill Christ,
who he views as a potential threat to his throne.
And in the massacre Isaac's wife, Rebecca and his son are killed.
And so Isaac holds a grudge against price for the next 30 years and even bribes
a Roman soldier to allow him to participate in the beating of Jesus prior to the
crucifixion, but in the middle of this torture Christ turns to Isaac and says,
I go on my rest,
but you shall wonder without rest you shelter Harry in this world till the day I
come again. And so Isaac finds himself unable to return home,
but is driven by a constant compulsion to wonder the earth.
He roams the earth for centuries until he witnesses a woman being attacked by
inquisitors during the Spanish inquisition.
And so we see that the woman is identical to his wife and tries to save her,
but to no avail as she dies in his arms,
but her refusal to blame God for her death led the stranger to decide to repent
of a sense and begin serving God as the Phantom stranger.
And so upon hearing his confession to the priest,
God offers the Phantom stranger,
a release from his punishment where the stranger turns him down saying that
there's more darkness in the world that needs to be dispelled.
And so the second version of the Phantom stranger's origin that we're told is
also biblical in nature this time,
he was a man living in a city that had been condemned to be destroyed by God
because of its wickedness. However, because of his righteousness,
the man who would become the Phantom stranger was visited by an angel who told
him that because he was the only good person in the city.
His life would be spared,
but not wanting to see his family and his fellow citizens perish.
While he lived,
the man refused the angels mercy and punches a knife into his stomach,
so that he'll die with him.
And so the angel forces his soul back into his body and erases all his memories
of his past life while sentencing him to wonder the earth turning souls from
evil to good until there were none left in need of redemption.
Now the third version of his origin story involves a group of scientists seeking
to prolong the end of the universe by transferring energy from the big bang to
the end of the universe via time-travel as well.
The Phantom stranger shows up to tell them that what they're doing will have
catastrophic consequences.
One of the scientists who turns out to be an avatar of anti-life attacks the
Phantom stranger and carries on with a secret plan to end the universe by
draining the energy of the big bang,
thereby causing the universe to simply cease to exist the Phantom stranger,
however,
near the end of his life transfers his essence and power to another one of the
scientists who remarks that he now has unlimited power.
He then absorbs the energy of the end of the universe and redistributes it,
creating a new universe where he will serve as the Phantom stranger with the
impression being that this cycle will be repeated with every rebirth of
subsequent universes. And so finally,
we have another origin story rooted in biblical tradition,
this one being written by Alan Moore. Now when this version,
the Phantom stranger begins as an angel,
who's approached by an angel named ed trigon seeking to recruit him to Satan's
rebellion against Yahweh, which is the Hebrew name for God.
He refuses to take aside, which ends up getting him cast out of heaven.
But instead of being banished to hell,
he's doomed to walk the earth forever as the Phantom stranger. Now,
while all these origins all presented originally without any context as to which
one is true,
the fallen angel story was seemingly corroborated by John Constantine and the
trench coat brigade mini series published by vertigo in 1999.
This origin was rec count. However, in the new fifties,
you continuity with 2012,
the Phantom stranger number zero written by Dan to dial now in this version,
the Phantom stranger is Judas Iscariot, the disciple of Jesus,
the betrayed him to the Jewish high priest and exchange for 30 pieces of silver
and so ashamed of what he'd done, Judas killed himself,
but it's taken to a room where he's judged by a council of divine beings as one
of the three greatest transgressors in the history of mankind judge and returned
to his body in the field where he betrayed Jesus with the coins he received now
bound to a skin.
And so a voice from the sky tells Judas to put on a robe that it appeared beside
him, which was revealed to have belong to Jesus before he was crucified.
And so Judas dawns the rope and is informed that his penance for sin is to walk
the earth until his debt was paid,
where upon he would become an agent for the greater good.
And so we wonder is the earth for thousands of years,
until the voice commands him to seek out a detective named John Corrigan,
who's arguing with his boss over a missing persons case involving his fiance
twin. Now Corgan quits and storms out of the office,
but as approached by the Phantom stranger, who offers to take him to where,
when as being held, unbeknownst to the stranger,
he's leading Corgan into a trap and he's killed,
which releases the divine entity known as the specter,
the embodiment of divine vengeance,
who immediately recognizes the Phantom stranger as the one who betrayed him
before.
And so ushering in the transformation of Corgan into the specter causes one of
the coins to fall from the Phantom strangers signaling that he's a step closer
to paying off the debt for a sense.
And so with all those different potential origins out of the way,
let's get into the Phantom strangers Howers first of all,
he is immortal and immune to the effects of aging or disease. He possesses vast,
magical abilities. The upper limits of which are not known.
He can travel between dimensions as well as through time.
I can wield mythical energy offensively in the form of glass or defensively to
ward off virtually any spell cats by any other magic user.
Although he is extraordinarily powerful,
he's frequently prohibited from intervening directly in events.
And so we have to observe and influence others from the sidelines.
The Phantom strangers seems to be nearly on mission,
knowing basically everything that is knowable,
except apparently that he was leading Jim Corgan to his death is that did
obviously taken by surprise.
But I assume this was hidden from him by a higher power that needed the events
to come to pass like BC's riders.
And so just to get a sense of how powerful the Phantom stranger is,
he's gone up against the Spector.
Who's one of the most powerful entities in DC comics and has not only held his
own,
but the fight actually had to be stopped by the presence because it was a threat
to the universe. And that's for how powerful has magical abilities art.
He was unaffected by magical energy that it allowed impulse to defeat Mr. Mixel,
Pedalec a powerful reality warping character. Furthermore,
his magical abilities are said to be beyond pacification and he does not rely on
traditional spells,
but is able to harness mystical energy and a more pure fashion.
Basically there is no defined limit as to how powerful the Phantom stranger
could be if he realized his full potential,
but we really get to see him even come close to his full potential because doing
so would resolve most storylines instantaneously.
And so he's usually relegated to being a background advisory character when he
shows up, but on the rare occasions that he does engage in battle,
he's proven himself to be one of the most powerful characters in the entirety of
the DC universe. And that's it. That's all we have.
The Phantom stranger lives up to his namesake.
He's a Phantom whose strange earth and most of the guys that we see out there
using powers, I don't know. That was my terrible attempt at a joke.
That being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you guys are new here to come as explained to make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and I will catch you all later.
[Inaudible].